the Joe Rogan experience lyses Tong PO
stop it stop it
bald ponytail is such a choice do that
why would you do bald ponytail so funny
man
is there a girl out there that [ __ ]
guys only who are bald with ponytail
sadly yeah
come on sadly someone who looks the ball
ponytail guy if he does that work I what
says what's his game yeah money
speaking of ball ponytail did you see
what happened in the game when LeBrons
hair fell off I somebody showed me a
photo but I thought that looks so
without real it's real looked at the guy
is a [ __ ] billionaire he's a god
amongst men yeah he's a giant super
athlete with a really well shaped head
what the [ __ ] man shave your head shaved
your goddamn pill up that picture cuz I
want to see the [ __ ] he's got some
nonsense glued on his head that's like
not his hair he's a toupee look at that
look at that
she's his hair moved up and someone had
to tell him it says it all thanks bro so
you get the the bandana back in place
his hair moved wait why did he yeah he's
got some [ __ ] glued on his head bro the
guy he's handsome he's a superior
physical specimen LeBron's hair falls
out during game a thneed AVA system hey
dawg your hairs up your hair fell off
dawg oh he did tell him yeah hey ice
always points to sign what's up with
your hair he's laughing are they friends
yeah he's the only guy starts telling
he's the only guy on a team that could
pride tell him that anybody also gets
traded immediately was [ __ ] was hair
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] last night he didn't
have the head head on it yeah let me fix
it up nice Oh God he did have the head
bed oh no did not last night look at
this that's nonsense what's going on
with his hair hey hey some walls your
hair yo dawg
he's laughing yo Dawg gotta fix that
just so weird like why would why does he
want to deal with that you know it is
cuz he hasn't accepted it yet yeah but
also he's still young he's 35 35 ever
friend his mind he's like the young guy
you know but shave your [ __ ] that's
like John Cena grew his hair out now I
saw him on a [ __ ] billboard and he
has long hair
always had like short military cut you
know
[Applause]